هذه غزه حيث يراد للحياه ان تصغر الى حجم
خيمه وحفنه طحين ويصير الاستثناء قاعده
والبديهي
امتيازا معان معنا كثير لا يجوع الناس
هناك من فقر ولا تشرده كوارث الطبيعه انه
حصار جماعي عقاب يرقى في القانون الدولي
الى جريمه ضد الانسانيه يطهون الطعام على
شكل وجبات بما توفر وترنيم هتاف واحد لما
تخذل كل برايا بتصيح يا
رب لما السلم يقلب حارب ويتسكر
الباب لما الاخلا ينكروا من الماضي ما طاب
لما في غزه بنقصر بصيح يا رب مليونان و300
الف انسان هم اهل غزه المتناقص امواج
تتحرك داخل القطاع الصغير في الشمال حيث
يتواصل القصف والمقاومه يعيش اكثر من نصف
مليون يصعب تحديد رقم فالد نتاج متابعه
ورعايه وهم متروكون الجحيم على الارض وفق
الامم المتحده يزداد سوءا المستشفيات خارج
الخدمه والمساعدات المقطره مسيج بالدم عند
دوار الكويت في مدينه غزه سمع الناس قبل
خمسه ايام بوصول مساعدات فشن الاحتلال
عليهم غاره وقتل عشرات وقد بدا الاهالي
منذ نحو شهرين بالنزوح جنوبا حيث تروج
روايه المنطقه الامنه التي يكذبها الشهود
والوقائع امشينا حافيين الجزاز كان على
الارض ولا فرقت غطسنا في
الوحل الوح
الممنوع يهجم الاحتلال حاليا على خان يونس
مركز الجنوب فينز اهلها نحو رفح وعلى
الطريق تتوالى شهادات مرعبه مما وقع مثلها
شمالا عن تنكيل واختفاء وحتى اعدام ميداني
جرائم متفرقه داخل الجريمه الكبرى لمؤسسات
حقوق الانسان سكري لمؤسسات حقوق الطفل
سكري لحقوق المراه يا ام المراه العالمه
تعالوا شوفوا نسائنا في هنا في غزه رفح
المحاذيه للمعبر يحشر نحو مليون و300 ال
انسان في منطقه تتسع لربع مليون يتجمع
نازحو غزه في نحو 200 مركز ايواء تابع
لوكاله الاونروا المهدده بالتوقف بعدما
استقوت اكبر الدول المانحه على المدنيين
الفلسطينيين واوقفت التمويل في تماه مع
الحمله الاسرائيليه من بقي بلا مركز او
بيت فله خيام البلاستيك في ذروه الشتاء
ومن لا يجد سيفتر طرقات اختنقت بلا ماء
للشرب ولا مرافق صحيه والطعام شحيح شيء لم
يسبق ان رايت مثله يقول الامين العام
للامم المتحده الشهر الخامس يقترب ويدخل
حصار غزه في عداد الحصارات الاسطوريه في
التاريخ لكنه في قرن بلغ من حداثته ان صار
بامكان البشريه ان تتفرج ثم تصمت الا من
سؤال كيف يصمدون ماذا يفعلون يقولون انهم
يفعلون ما يفعله الواقف عند الجدار الاخير
ويدفعون ثمنا عظيما لمجد اسمه
الكرامه